throughout the years we have never
interfered
until now
[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
oh marvel just dropped their first
trailer for eternals
the trailer is stacked with familiar
faces like gemma chan
brian tyree henry kamal nanjiani salma
hayek and angelina jolie
the film which is directed by newly
minted oscar winner chloe zhao
takes us back to the earliest years of
the mcu before iron man captain marvel
and even before captain america
timothy chalamet has been tapped to play
a young willy wonka
the oscar-nominated actor will star in
wonka a big screen reimagining of raw
doll's classic children's book
charlie and the chocolate factory the
film will be directed by paul king who
wrote the screenplay along with simon
farnaby the story will focus on willy
wonka and his adventures
prior to opening the world's most famous
chocolate factory the film marks the
third time warner brothers has taken on
the story of wonka
with actors gene wilder and johnny depp
previously playing the iconic character
and it finally happened john boyega has
confirmed that he is set to star and
attack the block
too a decade after its original release
boyega will reprise his role as moses in
the sci-fi cult classic film
which helped launch his career the
actors shared his excitement about the
project
saying it's been a decade since attack
the block was released and so much has
changed since then
i'm excited to see this heightened story
return to the streets of london
moses has remained one of my favorite
characters to play and bringing him back
is such a huge honor
joe corners who wrote and directed the
2011 film will also
write and direct the sequel
well it looks like summer movie season
is back and with theaters opening back
up the summer lineup has a great mix of
comedies
drama horror and yes even a marvel movie
and here to break down everything you
need to know about what's coming to the
big screen this summer
is writer at slate karen hahn karen
we made it to the summer i can't believe
it i can't believe it's summer i can't
believe it's gonna happen and that we
might be able to go to see
movies that's still a completely crazy
concept to me we're gonna have so many
movies to see and it's
like i'm so excited so how about you
tell me
what you think is going to be the
biggest film
this summer i think there are a few
contenders but the first thing that
really jumps to mind is the movie
adaptation of in the heights
i feel like every trailer that i've seen
for even like pre-pandemic has made me
cry
even though i'm not like that musical's
biggest fan like just seeing that has
made me think like oh my god like
it's gonna be an emotional experience
and especially like having a big
blockbuster that's a musical
in theaters right after this pandemic i
think is going to be a huge draw to
theaters
i didn't expect you to say that i'd
expect it so there's so many movies
coming out
but you're absolutely right because it's
more of an event it's kind of like a
musical thing
you're gonna have people listening to it
afterwards you're going to have them
like singing it making parodies and
stuff like that
so yeah it's going to be a big event and
it's definitely going to define the
summer and you know
maybe they'll be this will be a summer
thing what about
your most anticipated film for me it's
definitely something on a slightly
smaller scale i would say that my most
anticipated for the summer is the green
knight just because i feel like that's
another one of those movies that had a
release date at the beginning of the
pandemic that's just been pushed and
pushed and pushed
because they've been waiting for it to
be able to have the theatrical
experience rather than
just straight to streaming or something
like that i'm a huge fan of david larry
and like the most recent trailer
i felt went even wilder on the kind of
crazy
beautiful visuals that he's so good at
especially in this very like
mythological story this take on
arthurian legends
um everything about it looks so good and
also that all the jokes about it being
like dev patel summer like still feel
really valid
um and that feels like a good note also
to go into the summer with even if it's
not necessarily as much of an
like huge event film as in the heights
might be
yeah you cried in the in the heights
trailer i cried on this trailer this is
the one that made it oh yeah
any specific moment that made you cry
just overall just the second
it started i can't wait to see this but
yeah you're right this is going to be
one you definitely want to just
like have that full big experience in
the theater so yeah great great choice
what smaller film do you think people
should be looking out for well i guess
this is now
two a24 films that i'm naming so i don't
know that i can call them small
anymore but i think it is for a24
we all love them it's hard not to um but
i think zola is kind of maybe the
less um blockbustery release that i
would point people to just because like
that initial twitter thread that the
story is based on is so crazy and
went viral in its own right and the
combination of talent in this movie
janiksa bravo um
taylor page riley keogh everyone in the
movie is absolutely incredible and the
trailers look like they're doing
something
kind of fun not necessarily
straightforward to tell the story which
is i think the way to go when you are
adapting something that is basically a
twitter tall tale you know
don't get lost in the big films you
definitely gotta check out stuff like
that for sure
i wanna talk about something uh you were
involved in you were the creator of the
bong
hive craze for the parasite can
premiere first of all tell us what that
is and then
tell me what the next craze like film
hive you're going to make
so the bong had like really like the
overall
generally the term is to describe all of
us who are fans of
ho um we were commenting just before
recording like i have my parasite poster
right here i love it
show off show off the bong juno love
um that kind of just started like as we
were in line to go see
parasite um the pres one of the press
degrees of parasite can it's just
something that just popped into my head
i was like bongive bongheim should i
tweet bongai
and then from there it just took off to
a degree that like i had no idea that it
was gonna go
that far um during like parasites oscar
campaign
as far as like what's next for the hype
train
i would love to say like it's gonna be
the green night or it's gonna be
something else but like you really have
to wait to see
after you watch the movie because like
the hype took off like after seeing
parasite because
the feeling of like coming out of a
theater after you've seen a movie that's
so perfect it's really
an indescribable and you can't recreate
that high
um and so you got to wait and see like
what's going to trigger that response
you can't unfortunately not something
you can tell from trailers that's kind
of ominous you're like i'm waiting to
see what i create the next hive for
all right well i'm very impressed with
me
director's just slipping you at 20. come
on
all right well if if people want to
follow you personally and maybe find out
what the next hive is going to be
where can people find you um you can
find me on twitter
at karenweihan that's where i retweet
like my work from slate and stuff and
generally
i'm on letterboxed and instagram as well
but twitter's i think the main
place to go isn't it always all right
well thank you so much karen
have a great one thank you so much
in theaters this week is a quiet place
part 2
and cruella
that'll happen a bomb
i think
following the deadly events at home the
abbott family must
now face the terrors of the outside
world as they continue to fight for
survival in
silence forced to venture into the
unknown
they quickly realized that the creatures
that hunt by sound are not the only
threats that lurk beyond the sand path
this second installment sees the return
of emily blunt as evelyn abbott along
with returning cast members noah jupas
marcus
and milicent simmons is regan and
available to watch on vudu
is the unholy and the water man
the water man is real legend has it that
he's still living up by the lake
searching the waters and the woods for
his wife so he could bring her back from
the dead
[Music]
gunner sets out on a quest to save his
ill mother by searching for a mythical
figure who possesses the secret to
immortality
the water man after enlisting the help
of a mysterious local girl
joe they journey together into the
remote wild horse forest
but the deeper they venture the stranger
and more dangerous the force becomes
their only hope for rescue is gunner's
father who will stop at nothing to find
them and in the process
we'll discover who his son really is the
film stars rosario dawson
alfred molina and david a yellow okay
well that's it for today but before you
go
leave us a comment and let us know what
summer film you're most looking forward
to seeing
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you